dans les rues dévastées de mario paul
l'armée ukrainienne se prépare à une
ultime bataille côté on est paré
chauffard l'ennemi a terminé la phase de
mouvement et le regroupement de ses
unités
et les a déplacés vers le territoire des
régions de donetsk et de lougansk nous
croyons que des combats intenses se
tiendront dans ces territoires
dans un futur proche des snipers
assiégée depuis près de 50 jours par
l'armée russe l'étau se resserre sur les
dernières troupes qui défendent la ville
stratégique de mario paul et notamment
un complexe industriel de plusieurs
usines non aux obstacles ou des soldats
d'ukrainiens sont coincés les
séparatistes pro russes affirment
désormais contrôler entièrement la zone
portuaire de la ville alors que de
nombreux civils sont toujours retranchés
dans les ruines de mario paul le
président ukrainien il lançait un
avertissement aux nombreuses et l'un des
porte-parole des envahisseurs a déclaré
qu'il envisageait d'utiliser des armes
chimiques contre les défenseurs de
marioupol nous prenons cela très au
sérieux pro tech journée on visite dans
l'extrême orient russe pour parler de la
guerre en ukraine avec son homologue et
allié biélorusse le président poutine a
qualifié de noble son offensive
militaire avant de menacer les pays
occidentaux de subir les conséquences
des sanctions imposées à son pays